elise lucet qui présentera présente cash
investigations et un envoyé spécial ce
soir voilà sur france 2 donc spécial
d'ailleurs sur notre nabot 6 1
exactement
et elle n'a pas hésité à la tite par
kadri plein de gens la journaliste a
révélé qu'elle impose certaines
conditions fans aussi qui lui demande un
seule fille dans la rue
regardez c'est vrai que tout le monde
commence à parler d' élise lucet mois
moi je vous racontais un truc j'aimerais
que j'ai obligé de la kiffer fin mai et
attention lille eden lévis on s'aime
bien ahmad el eulma elma elle m'a aidé
un jour sur les 10 et lancez vous nous
raconterez élise lucet est une femme qui
on le sait dans ces émissions n'a pas
souvent sa langue dans sa poche
à la tête du magazine carte
investigations il n'est pas rare de voir
la journaliste alpaguer un pdg du cac 40
ou apostrophé un ancien président pour
lui sommé de se justifier mais a
contrario dans la vie de tous les jours
et en interview la journaliste de france
2 a toujours paru calme une attitude qui
semble quelque peu changé ces derniers
temps exemple récent lorsque la ministre
marlène schiappa s'était permis de
critiquer la forme de populisme qu'elle
ressentait parfois dans le traitement de
l'info par lé magazine envoyé spécial et
cash investigations il n'en fallait pas
plus pour que la journaliste sortent du
bois interrogé par télé loisirs elle
déplore les déclarations de la ministre
elle devrait regarder plus souvent nos
émissions avant de critiquer elle n'en a
pas le temps je pense
elle est souvent débordés de travail un
comportement inédit de la part de la
journaliste qui confier également refusé
de prendre des selphy avec ceux qui lui
en demander quand je suis avec ma fille
et que je dois faire dit cette fille de
suite ce n'est pas toujours agréable je
demande d'ailleurs systématiquement aux
gens de ne pas lui postés sur les
réseaux sociaux et il ne respecte
alors selon vous elise lucet at elle
pris la grosse tête alors elise lucet
peut-être pris la grosse tête
voilà bah moi perso voilà je trouve que
c'est dans son rôle après voilà et dites
nous ce que vous en pensez vous alors je
sais pas si elle a pris la grosse tête
mais on peut aussi prendre en compte la
parano peut-être qu'elle est devenue un
petit peu parano dans sa cape sicot
logiquement et qu'à la calade sa tête
dans le jargon la scène de coeur qui
l'attend sur une pile de trucs et que
c'est trop lourd pour elle et qu'elle
est devenue parano et ça peut prendre
rendez vous avec vous merci voilà si
vous avez des problèmes à l'ouest où
trouver kelly smith a pris la grosse
tête
c'est étonnant pour moi ce serait très
étonnant de sa part je les ai assez vu
souvent j'ai vu souvent parler avec des
personnes assez important dans des
moments assez difficiles et sur des
sujets plutôt technique
est ce que parce que la question aux
gènes et du mal à assimiler à un
journaliste à la vie de star
traditionnels après je ne sais pas où à
la presse qu'elle pourrait prendre la
grosse tête intellectuellement c'est pas
possible
l'accord soit vous pouvez le voir on
peut le voir on a déjà des éléments de
réponse est personne mais on a
interpellé le pape sur eux comme ça
comme si c'était lui lire quidam pour le
poser une question à savage n pas valeur
voir qu'on ne vienne lui demande une
photo ça ça la gêne alors été voir ça on
va devoir regarder avec le pas pour se
rappelle benni dengue s'est gardé le
pape
je ferai pas le pas la papamobile fait
son entrée à son troisième passage
elise se lance
votre santé nous parvenons à lui
remettre notre lettre et puis quelques
minutes plus tard votre santé dans le
cas grâce y avez vous tenté d'influencer
la justice argentine soupçonne gayda
votre sainteté dans le cas grassi
allez-vous tenter d'influencer la
justice argentine
non non benzema voire commander une
contre-enquête alors pas du tout alors
non mais ça ça a beaucoup choqué bien
sûr cet honneur
à quoi est-ce que le lien un protocole
qu'il faut respecter ça un chef d'état
comme les autres et de oppose pas des
caisses quoi elle s'attendait ce qu'ils
s'arrêtent qui sort des cahiers qui lui
fasse une explication non comme fer
valeurs du respect de l'homme et montre
qu'on s'attende pas à ce qu'on met alors
alors alors isabelle morini bosc qui a
mené avec qui j -c va nous dire ce
qu'elle en pense qu'ils aimeraient ils
disaient oui mais non est ce qu'elle a
pris la grosse tête elle appelle un
concept elle est cachée elle est tout le
temps comme ça mais les caches aurait
cédé sur la rue avec vous y allez catch
mais ça c'est pas compatible
quand on est dans la rue mais qu'elle
doit lui dire ouh là cette fois c'est
vrai qu'elle rend barre elle mais elle
est comme ça elle est comme ça quoi
mettre en vie de rembarrer turon battu
que j'adore mais moi j'en attends alors
la pédophilie n'est toi tu es le rapide
mais le net
rachel parce que là précisément l apos
tôt elle apostrophe et le pape sur une
histoire de pédophilie oui mais pas la
fausse arrivée comme ça non après et
comme sage mais pas l'approcher comme ça
je suis désolé maintenant il faut avoir
du respect à avoir quand même là dessus
j'ai rien contre elle a vraiment barré
moi je m arrête des gens qui font des
seuls six mois j'ai du mal parce que
c'est quand même bien alors il ya quand
même des gens sur eure sur twitter la
plus grande marque à raymond c'est quand
même bien des gens mais qu'ils disent
mais qui demandent des selles fille
élise lucet voilà d'où tu me magnée toi
mais j'en retiens quand même des garçons
cravate rappellent ils attendent une
[Applaudissements]
l'artiste à la gauche de semi retraite
at-il eu demande d'aller au 16 mai voilà
mais c'est tout mais pas de celle çi oui
je suis d'accord avec elle juste pour
les enfants faut pas qu'il faut pas
prendre des photos avec ses enfants mais
elle c'est un personnage public elle a
choisi d'aller à l'atp pas la télé qui
est venu frapper chez elle vient faire
la télé la terre non mais les mecs sont
marrants même les jantes en plein de
vedettes plein certains oiseaux moi
j'aime pas les seules filles aiment bien
aller en vacances sur les îles thème
bien roulé dans des bennes de l'homme
mais ça peut faire des sauts elle bat la
raison mais tu sais ça fait partie du
métier d'accord avec moi si l'on veut
pas de cette spéciale l 100 km h mais
c'est un exemple c'est un exemple ils
veulent les bonnes choses des bonnes
tables au restaurant ne veulent pas
faire de cette fête et je suis assez
d'accord avec lui sur ses seins il
d'oriens voilà je dis la vérité ça fait
parti d'un coup il prend compte uplay
savais pas christine kelly
moi j'ai travaillé à france 3 et allan
rock nommé à l'époque tous les jours
non mais tous les journalistes à
l'intérieur de la rédaction la traitait
d'arrogante à l'internât rédacteurs wind
dont je ne pense pas c'est quelqu'un qui
a changé comme elle dit elle et cache
cependant des télécoms qui a évolué elle
a toujours été comme ça et je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui arrogance rime avec
compétence parce qu'à l'extérieur à
l'antenne
alex mais c'est dommage d'ailleurs car
au gans rime avec compétence cacher
parce que le téléspectateur ils l'aiment
justement cette juge ducey arrogante à
l'ontologie même si la rédaction en tout
cas la trouve arrogante
à l'intérieur c'est alors il ya des gens
aussi qu'il dise voilà quand elle est
riche comprend si elle avec les chiens
qu'elle n'ait pas envie qu'on la voit
sur les réseaux sociaux on comprend que
les enseignants quand elle est tout seul
on dirait que voilà les bonnes affaires
alors on va on va voir on va voir ce que
vous enfoncez oui à 55%
non à 45 ans ils sont jamais d'accord
avec isabelle ce soir les
téléspectateurs